mysteriöse ruinen im süden italiens
ein tunnel wie aus dem herrn der ringe
führt mitten rein in einen berg
eine kolossale anlage an der
amerikanischen westküste
ein unheimlicher ort besonders wenn er
in nebel gehüllt ist als hätten die
geister gearbeitet die plötzlich
verschwunden sind
ein inselparadies mit grausamer
geschichte
einige bilder sind mit blut gemalt sie
erinnern an die düstere vergangenheit
der insel und eine geisterstadt die dem
wandel der zeit zum opfer fiel sieht aus
wie aus einem horrorfilm
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie
verlassen
[Musik]
in einer scharfen felsschlucht im
us-bundesstaat west virginia ist ein
rätselhafter ort
[Musik]
die stadt liegt direkt am fuß der
schlucht zum schutz der felsen
sie ist ziemlich versteckt
sie mag abgelegen sein aber eigentlich
wirkt die stadt ganz gewöhnlich
als würde da eine szene für einen film
gedreht der im späten 19 oder frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert spielt poker
spielern und freudenmädchen
als wären die leute bis gestern noch da
gewesen und dann urplötzlich
weitergezogen
die häuser entlang der bahnlinie
scheinen völlig intakt
sind geschäfte und werkstätten
alles was eine stadt ausmacht
aber plötzlich merkst du dass sie total
ausgestorben ist
das ist keine typische geisterstadt in
der alles verrottet die häuser sehen aus
als bräuchten sie nur ein paar
schönheitsreparaturen
dann könnte man wieder einziehen und das
licht einschalten
einige häuser haben goldglänzende
tapeten feine mosaiken und sogar einen
gewaltigen safe der offen steht als wäre
er gestern erst ausgeräumt worden
andere gebäude haben sich nicht so gut
gehalten
an den hängen stehen verfallene alte
häuser die sehen aus wie aus einem
horrorfilm
[Musik]
ab und zu kommt immer noch ein zug durch
alles deutet darauf hin dass hier früher
viel los war
ein stück weiter ragt ein seltsames
bauwerk aus dem nebel
und genau dieses turmartige haus bei den
gleisen verrät einiges über die stadt
beides termins her
[Musik]
vor mehr als einem jahrhundert pulsiert
an dieser stelle das leben liebherr
kowski ranger im nationalpark
kennt die geschichte
die meisten leute die hierher kommen
denken sie sind am ende der welt
tatsächlich ging hier anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ganz schön die
post ab
1904 errichtet die chesapeake energy
company einen bahnhof
die schlucht ist nur mit der bahn zu
erreichen
zwei jahre später hat die 90 kilometer
lange strecke bereits 36 haltestellen
und die bedeutendste ist hier in firmen
[Musik]
und war das verkehrszentrum und die
wichtigste stadt in der schlucht
es gab zahlreiche geschäfte und ein
großes freizeitangebot
heute ist es kaum noch vorstellbar aber
damals halten hier 20 passagierzüge pro
tag
betrieben werden sie mit der kohle aus
dem kraftwerk das immer noch das
wahrzeichen der stadt ist
die lokalzeitungen feiern firmen als die
größte aller kleinstädte
ihre boomjahre verdankt die stadt dem
sogenannten schwarzen gold
von mitte des 19 bis mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war kohle das
herzstück der amerikanischen wirtschaft
es gab die stahlindustrie kohle
betriebenen züge die schlucht am jun
river zählte zu den reichhaltigsten
abbaugebieten sondern bestpreise ist
meine
flügel in den bergen rund um die
schlucht wurde nicht einfach irgendeine
kohle gefördert
sondern ein echtes qualitätsprodukt
das wertvolle gut wirkt der zug nach
ganz amerika geliefert und zurück fließt
geld
die kohle bringt jede menge kohle
[Musik]
mit der infrastruktur kann man die
banken die menschen
[Musik]
die banken zählen zu den reichsten in
ganz west virginia
trotzdem ist firmen zuallererst
eisenbahnerstadt mit ständig wechselnden
arbeitern die ganz spezielle bedürfnisse
haben
die minenarbeiter kamen und gingen aber
natürlich gab es auch festes personal
die stadt braucht er alles was eine
typische großstadt ausmachte metzger
supermärkte schuster es gab sogar einen
rotlichtbezirk
gründervater firmen ein strenger baptist
verbietet jeglichen alkoholkonsum in der
stadt
die hotels in der weiteren umgebung aber
scheren sich nicht darum sie sind
berühmt für ihr feuchtfröhliches
nachtleben besonders hoch her geht es in
einem laden auf der anderen seite des
flusses
das dann glen hotel war schwer angesagt
seine zeit war es ganz schön extravagant
es hatte drei stockwerke und 100 zimmer
viele geschäftsleute stiegen da ab
im dann glen hotel feiern kohle barone
und minenarbeiter gemeinsam die nächte
durch drum herum entwickelt sich ein
rotlichtviertel
in bergbau städten ging es für
gewöhnlich ziemlich rau zu die männer
waren fast unter sich im untergrund
entwickelte sich eine schattenwirtschaft
um ihre wünsche und bedürfnisse zu
befriedigen
das dann glen hotel hatte einen
schlechten ruf
institution glücksspiel und angeblich
die längste pokerpartie der geschichte
der legende nach dauert sie 14 jahre
das dann glen hotel wird immer populärer
um die prohibitionsgesetz kümmert es
sich wenig razzien gehören zum alltag im
juli 1930 aber hat all das ein ende das
hotel brent bis auf die grundmauern
nieder
[Musik]
die umstände sind mysteriös ein
rivalisierender hotelbesitzer wird
beschuldigt den brand gelegt zu haben
[Musik]
es gibt verschiedene theorien warum das
hotel abgebrannt ist aber in
wirklichkeit weiß es niemand
schon vor dem verschwinden ihres
berühmtesten hotels ist die stadt firmen
in schwierigkeiten
schuld daran die position der siegeszug
des autos und der rasante wandel der
zeit
die technologie veränderte sich der
tagebau löste allmählich den
untertagebau ab wie er am new river
praktiziert wurde
nach und nach schlossen die bergwerke
die hoch zeit war vorbei und das
geschäft ab
schlechte karten für die stadt
bis in die 50er jahre hinein hält die
eisenbahnfahrt am leben
dann folgt ein weiterer vernichtender
schlag
mit der ankunft des dieselmotors war
furmans schicksal besiegelt die in
formen gab es eine große werkstatt für
dampflokomotiven
dieselmotoren waren weniger
wartungsintensiv
deshalb hatten die bahngesellschaften
keinen grund mehr firmen weiter zu
betreiben
die ganze stadt war praktisch rund um
die dampflok erbaut worden das alles
wurde plötzlich überflüssig
immer mehr menschen verlassen die stadt
1984 schließt die bahn ihre letzten
büros
heute hat dann die güterzüge ohne
anzuhalten durch die geisterstadt
trotzdem erinnert immer noch vieles an
die glanzvollen zeiten
[Musik]
charmant ist ein sinnbild für den auf-
und abschwung der kohle in den usa
ihre existenz verdankt die stadt den
kräften des wandels und dem folgten auch
die menschen
[Musik]
in kalifornien ein stück nördlich von
san francisco ist ein enormes
betonbecken in den boden eingelassen
[Musik]
es sieht aus wie ein langgestrecktes
stadion direkt am ufer ein riesiges
leeres loch horst entität
an der seite gegen stufen hoch wie bei
einer maya pyramide umgekehrt
die erbauer haben hier viel geld und
mühe reingesteckt
die schier endlose grundfläche hält
erste hinweise parat
[Musik]
haben es mit einer sehr soliden
konstruktion zu tun weiter unten ändert
sich der eindruck
die letzten paar stufen bröckeln
regelrecht weg
dass sie dafür ein anderes material
verwendet haben das ergibt keinen sinn
warum wurde diese anlage stillgelegt
oder ist sie vielleicht unter ihrem
eigenen gewicht zusammengebrochen
die geschichte beginnt im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
während der osten der vereinigten
staaten bereits eine gute infrastruktur
und funktionierende verteidigungsanlagen
aufweist sind die städte im westen kaum
geschützt
nachdem in kalifornien gold entdeckt
worden war
benötigte die region schleunigst einen
starken staat zur verteidigung
weiter nördlich werden die letzten
schlachten gegen die ureinwohner
geschlagen und auch in mittelamerika
toben kriege mehr island eine insel
direkt vor der küste bietet sich als
standort für die erste marinewerft an
mit der fertigstellung im jahr 1891
beginnt ein neuer abschnitt in der
geschichte der usa wie bruce christensen
ingenieur im ruhestand erklärt
an dieser stelle begann für die
abwehrkräfte der us navy eine neue ära
an die 150 meter lang nach fast 20
jahren bauzeit ist das meer einen
top-job nummer eins einsatzbereit
in diesem trockendock konnte eine ganz
neue generation großer schiffe repariert
und überholt werden
das trockendock leistet einen wertvollen
beitrag zur absicherung der westküste
trotzdem droht gefahr von ganz
unerwarteter seite
der größte teil des docks besteht aus
riesigen granitblöcken die mussten per
schiff angeliefert werden das war sehr
aufwändig
granit ist wahnsinnig schwer der preis
spielt also keine rolle das ganze sollte
einfach möglichst lange halten
doch in die unteren stufen wurde
offensichtlich nicht viel investiert
man fragt sich unweigerlich ob der miese
zustand der unteren stufen der grund für
die stilllegung gewesen ist
zwei ganz unterschiedliche
baumaterialien und beide spielen eine
wichtige rolle in der geschichte des
trockendocks
1898 schlägt mutter natur zum ersten mal
zu
wie solide das dort gebaut ist zeigte
sich als ein starkes erdbeben die insel
erschüttert
alles drumherum fiel in sich zusammen
das doktor gegen blieb nahezu
unbeschädigt
[Musik]
die schäden an den unteren stufen sind
vielmehr die folge eines späteren umbaus
der anlage
entlang der küste entstehen weitere
verteidigungsanlagen die für mehr
sicherheit sorgen die wichtigste rolle
spielt trotzdem weiterhin mehr island
während des ersten weltkriegs wird hier
die uss wort gebaut
die uss wort ist ein zerstörer der vix
klasse
benannt wird sie nach james ward dem
ersten marineoffizier der während des
amerikanischen bürgerkriegs ums leben
kam im ersten weltkrieg werden zerstörer
dringend benötigt also wird die uss wort
in nur 17 tagen fertiggestellt am 24
juli 1918 wird sie in dienst gestellt
sieben tage um ein kriegsschiff zu bauen
einfach phänomenal
nachdem die uss wort vom stapel gelassen
wurde kommt sie für den feinschliff ins
trockendock
danach beginnt ihr aktiver dienst
es dauert aber noch bis zum zweiten
weltkrieg das schiff und mit ihm die
marinewerft so richtig für militärische
furore sorgen
1921 wird die wort zunächst eingemottet
doch genau 20 jahre später wird sie
wieder gebraucht und zum schnell
transporter umgebaut
jetzt kommt ihre große stunde
vom pazifik aus drohte potenziell große
gefahr
deshalb brauchten die vereinigten
staaten entlang der westküste wer fähige
marinestützpunkt
seit jahren wachsen die spannungen
zwischen japan und den usa
einer diplomatischen bemühungen sind
vergebens
im dezember 1941 staaten die japaner
einen sorgfältig geplanten
überraschungsangriffe
ihr ziel die us flotte im pazifik
ohne formelle kriegserklärung greifen
sie den hafen von pearl harbor an
[Musik]
währenddessen jagd die uss ward ein
japanisches zwei mann bot
die uss wort feuerte die ersten
amerikanischen schüsse im zweiten
weltkrieg ab sie bekam ein japanisches u
boot ins visier und nutzte die
gelegenheit
es ist bemerkenswert dass das erste
schiff das japanische opfer forderte an
der kalifornischen küste in der werft
von mehr island gebaut wurde
der angriff auf pearl harbor war einer
der schlimmsten momente in der us
amerikanischen geschichte der
gegenschlag durch die uss wort aber gab
die richtung vor die usa schlugen zurück
während des zweiten weltkriegs leiste
trockendock nummer eins ganze arbeit
zum reparieren beschädigter schiffe ist
es perfekt geeignet
[Musik]
die punkte am anderen ende fühlen das
becken mit wasser so hoch wie hier
draußen
das wasser die richtige höhe erreicht
öffnet sich das tor der sogenannten kiss
jetzt kann das reparaturbedürftige
schiff einfahren
danach wird das dock wieder verschlossen
das wasser fließt ab und die arbeiten
können beginnen
soll im pazifik weiter mitmischen zu
können mussten die usa ihre
kriegsschiffe die durch den beschuss der
japaner beschädigt worden waren zurück
nach hause bringen
dort wurden sie instand gesetzt und
wieder zurück in den kampf gegen die
japaner geschenkt
die usa müssen schnell und effizient
sein
diese werft trug entscheidend dazu bei
dass die us flotte während des kriegs
handlungsfähig pflicht
nach den beiden weltkriegen folgt der
kalte krieg und wieder spielt mehr
island eine wichtige rolle
aus dieser zeit stammen auch die
bröckelnden stufen
entwickelte sich von einem dock in dem
vornehmlich kriegsschiffe gebaut und
instand gesetzt wurde zu einem ort an
dem jetzt u-boote repariert wurden diese
hatten die aufgabe sowjetische schiffe
im pazifik zu überwachen
in den späten 70ern werden weitere
stufen und ein abschnitt am ende
hinzugefügt so passen auch größere
schiffe ins trockendock
[Musik]
die zusätzlichen schichten und die
bröckelnden stufen wurden nachträglich
hinzugefügt
trotz ihrer bedeutenden rolle im kalten
krieg wird die anlage 1993 stillgelegt
von da an beginnen die unteren stufen zu
brettern
dem granit dagegen kann der zahn der
zeit nichts anhaben
es ist erstaunlich dass die jüngeren
bauteile besonders die zusätzlichen
stufen heute im schlechtesten zustand
sind
[Musik]
mehr als ein jahrhundert lang hat das
trockendock bei der verteidigung der
westküste eine wichtige rolle gespielt
ohne seine dienste wäre die geschichte
womöglich ganz anders verlaufen
wer die sogenannten feuer felder in der
nähe von neapel besucht betritt eine
andere faszinierende welt
[Musik]
im schatten des vesuvs des vulkans der
die stadt pompeji unter sich begrub
existiert ein erstaunliches
unterirdisches labyrinth
der tunnel ist wie aus dem herrn der
ringe er führt dich mitten hinein in
einen berg wie in bordeaux
dieser ort ist voller mythen und
mysterien
erscheint wie der eingang zur unterwelt
alles deutet darauf hin dass die anlage
vor mehr als 2000 jahren errichtet wurde
einige wissenschaftler vermuten dass es
sich hier um ein rituelles zentrum
gehandelt haben könnte
[Musik]
wieder wurde etwas in szene gesetzt das
war nicht bloß ein tunnel von anna
ist komplexen das netz aus höhlen und
tunneln ist sehr komplex da stecken
echte baum heißt dahinter
es gab ein geheimnisvolles orakel ein
orakel der toten der eingang zur
unterwelt
das unterirdische system und die
weitläufigen ruinen an der oberfläche
gehören zusammen
das war ein aufwendiges projekt mit
tunneln wasserleitungen seinen fresken
und mosaiken aus
[Musik]
wie ein palast da fragt man sich wer hat
da gelebt
einige der bekanntesten persönlichkeiten
der weltgeschichte gingen hier ein und
aus aber wozu kommen sie hierher
und welche geheimnisse verbergen sich
unter der oberfläche
im nachbar vulkan des vesuvs ist ein
rätselhaftes tunnelsystem
[Musik]
tausende von jahren behält es seine
geheimnisse für sich
doch um 1960 endet der dornröschenschlaf
plötzlich
[Musik]
höhlenforscher graziano ferrari
berichtet
an die 2000 jahre lang kam keine
menschenseele hierher
[Musik]
doch dann begannen britische und
amerikanische forscher mit ihren
untersuchungen das war ungefähr 1960
während der 60er gab es einen nato
stützpunkt in der nähe unter den leuten
die dort arbeiteten war auch ein
hobbyarchäologe
entdeckte die anlage der hobbyarchäologe
heißt robert patches ihm wird schnell
klar dass er auf etwas großes gestoßen
ist
zehn jahre lang gruppe die tunnel aus
während dieser zeit entwickelte er eine
reihe erstaunlicher theorie
hat glaubt dass die tunnel teil eines
religiösen zentrums waren
die ergebnisse mussten erst noch
überprüft werden
schließlich blieb die städte für die
nächsten 50 jahre wieder geschlossen und
verlassen
inzwischen widmet sich die forschung
wieder den rätseln des berges eine frage
lautet befindet sich hier das legendäre
toten orakel
graziano ferrari steigt in einen langen
tunnel hinab mit messgeräten überprüft
er ob giftige gase ausströmen
links ein tunnel sind wie aus einer
anderen welt extrem engen und kaum
schulter hoch man klettert auf leiter
nach unten und braucht gassensoren also
ist ziemlich gruselig
die erbauer des tunnels haben an
zahlreiche einbuchtungen verkürzen
gedacht sie wollten es nicht bloß ein
bisschen her machen sondern es so
richtig ausleuchten
[Musik]
der jet werte die lichter flut als beleg
für seine these dass hier religiöse
rituale veranstaltet wurden
die tunnel sind so eng dass man die
schultern ein drehen muss sie verlaufen
nicht geradeaus sondern winden sich
durch den berg
dann geht es plötzlich steil bergauf zu
einer art bühne
[Applaus]
der weg ist teil des ziels es wird immer
heißer
man spürt die vulkanische aktivität und
dass man dem erdinneren immer näher
kommt es riecht nach schwefel irgendwie
aufregend
[Musik]
und wofür der tunnel schließlich hin
der tunnel kreuz einen unterirdischen
wasserlauf eigentlich eine heiße quelle
aber in der mythologie war es womöglich
der berühmte fluss stücks der die toten
in die unterwelt transportierte
wo heute nur noch ein wasserbecken ist
soll einst der sagenumwobene fluss styx
geflossen sein
in der griechischen mythologie stellt er
die grenze zwischen der welt der
lebenden und der unterwelt da dem hades
robert petzold vermutet hier einen
landungssteg verbote die die menschen
zur anderen seite brachten
dieser tunnel geht unter dem wasser noch
weiter wir wissen noch nicht wohin er
führt das ist eines der geheimnisse
dieser fantastischen höhle
oberhalb des beckens liegt ein
besonderer raum ein verstecktes
sanktuarium
budget schließt daraus das tunnelsystem
sei eine kopie der unterwelt
er ist überzeugt auf das sogenannte
toten orakel gestoßen zu sein
griechen und römer glaubten
gleichermaßen an einen ort an dem eine
besondere priesterin lebte ein orakel
dass die zukunft vorhersagen
der legende nach ließen sich die
menschen in der glühenden hitze einer
höhle von der priesterin die zukunft
vorhersagen
heute vermutet die forschung das rätsel
der orakel gelöst zu haben
einer theorie zufolge praktizierten
sämtliche orakel an orten an denen heiße
dämpfe aufstiegen da erlebte praktisch
jeder mensch halluzinationen
die priesterinnen nutzten das aus
baehny bild von solchen schwefel dämpfen
würden wir heute wahrscheinlich genauso
auf ihre schau rein fallen wie die leute
vor 2000 jahren
einige der tournee und hören haben ihr
geheimnis bis heute nicht preisgegeben
andere liefern hinweise auf dem
zusammenhang zu den ruinen an der
oberfläche
[Musik]
hier war der dampf kanal
die er leitete den dampf unter diesem
doppelten boden
graziano ist überzeugt dass der
unterirdische tunnel eine sehr irdische
funktion hatte
demnach war dies ein dampfbad das
mithilfe vulkanischer energie betrieben
wurde
[Musik]
die anlage ließ die besucher von der
vulkanischen hitze profitieren es gab
heißes wasser dampfbäder heiße
badewannen aber auch becken mit kaltem
wasser war miteinander verbunden
dies ist das ehemalige römische heilbad
[Musik]
die ganze anlage war ein luxus-resort
für die römische elite reich verziert
mit wunderschönen mosaiken auf den
fußböden und fresken an den wänden
hier haben wir ein weiteres highlight
des heilbads
eine halbrunde wohnanlage
vom pool aus schaute man auf die
herrliche landschaft des golfs von porz
volley
wir haben männer wie julius cäsar und
cicero gebadet
waren meister und künstler am werk
das netz aus kammern und tanz tunneln
und wasserdicht ausgekleideten
unterirdischen kanälen ergibt ein
komplexes hydraulisches system
kuppel bauten wie der tempel der diana
der älter ist als das pantheon in rom
fungieren als kalt wasserbad
außerdem gibt es sonnenterrassen und
schwimmbäder mit spektakulären blick auf
die bucht
bei war berüchtigt für ausschweifungen
und skandale wir wissen dass caesar und
cicero regelmäßig dort waren
es war ein tummelplatz für die reichen
und berühmten
warum gerät das berühmte edel bat
schließlich in vergessenheit
schuld ist am ende die natur
die anlage existiert überhaupt nur wegen
der seismischen aktivität vor ort und
genau die führte auch zu ihrem untergang
wegen der vulkanischen aktivität hat
sich der boden auf den pflegerischen
feldern immer wieder gesenkt und gehoben
eines tages rutschte ein großer teil des
bades ins meer von da an war es nur noch
eine frage der zeit
heute ist die ruine für jeden zugänglich
trotzdem verirren sich nur selten
touristen hierher
forscher wie graziano ferrari versuchen
die letzten geheimnisse der mysteriösen
anlage zu lüften
obwohl die ruinen 2000 jahre alt sind
kann man sich noch sehr gut vorstellen
wie die menschen sich hier erholten
die bauwerke sind wunderschön und die
geschichten dahinter immer noch lebendig
im griff von nicola an der pazifikküste
costa ricas ein kleines paradies
eine insel mit palmen und traumstränden
wie sollen es war ein wunderbares stück
natur umgeben von tropischen gewässern
auf den ersten blick paradiesisch aber
dahinter verbirgt sich eine dunkle und
grausame vergangenheit
ist ein beliebtes urlaubsziel
aber dieser ort ist kein typischer
touristen hotspots die stimmung hier
verflucht und trostlos
ein rostiges in die jahre gekommenes
bier begrüßt die besucher es führt in
ein geheimnisvolles labyrinth wurzeln
und kletterpflanzen umranken die
überreste der ruinen büsche und bäume
wachsen aus den häusern
die wände sind übersät mit graffiti die
allerdings anders aussehen als
gewöhnlich
die bilder erzählen von schmerz und wut
auf den zweiten blick wird deutlich dass
einige bilder mit blut gemacht wurden
warum ist blut an den wänden welcher
dunkle spuk lastet auf diesem paradies
die insel ist schon zu der zeit bewohnt
als costa rica noch zu spanien gehört
isla san lucas ist berühmt berüchtigt
jahrhunderte lang diente sie den
spanischen konquistadoren als gefängnis
im sechzehnten jahrhundert wurden dort
einheimische stimme festgehalten die
überreste von metall gittern deuten
allerdings darauf hin dass das gefängnis
noch bis vor kurzem benutzt wurde
1871 erhält das inzwischen unabhängige
costa rica unter präsident thomas
claudia roth iris eine eigene verfassung
gut jedes schafft die todesstrafe ab und
macht die insel zum staatsgefängnis die
gefangenen erwartet ein düsteres
schicksal
das gefängnis auf der isla san lucas
[Musik]
hier landet und costa rica das
schlimmste verbrechen
die
auftragskiller alle waren dort
[Musik]
kein platz für zartbesaitete
die gefangenen bekämpfen einander nicht
mit großen händen sondern mit selbst
gefertigten machten der ehemalige
häftling in lausanne erinnert sich
gott sei dank habe ich so ein nachtreten
duell überstanden und kann heute davon
erzählen
hoffentlich erlebe ich so was nie wieder
grausamkeiten waren an der tagesordnung
kein wunder bei bis zu 70 häftlingen pro
zelle
jugendliche kaum älter als 14 wurden
zusammen mit schwerverbrechern
eingesperrt
hierzulande war für viele wie ein
todesurteil
die verfallenden wände sind mit graffiti
übersät
die zeichnungen an den zellen bänden
erzählen von den alltäglichen qualen der
häftlinge
es geht um leid schmerz und einsamkeit
um das verblassende roth einzelner
graffiti kursiert hartnäckig ein gerücht
[Musik]
angeblich wurden sie mit dem blut einer
krankenschwester gemalten gefängnis
ermordet wurde
[Musik]
aber nicht nur die häftlinge sind
gefährlich
auch die wachleute sind für ihre
brutalen methoden gefürchtet dazu zählen
verschiedene arten der folter und eine
besonders grausame form der bestrafung
menschenrechte waren hier in san lucas
lange kein thema
du konntest jederzeit ohne grund im loch
es war üblich häftlinge in eine dunkle
abwasser grube zu sperren tagelang
es war eine echte strafe da drin zu sein
waren lauter insekten es war einfach
unmenschlich
ich wünsche dass niemand
die gräueltaten waren an der
tagesordnung bis zu 70 gefangenen
teilten sich eine zelle auch jugendliche
gerade mal 14 jahre alt waren der gewalt
und den krankheiten ausgesetzt
verantwortlich für die gnadenlosen
methoden ist eine spezialeinheit der
polizei
es gab eine sondereinheit genannt lost
coco bosna als häftling hast du versucht
diesen typen möglichst aus dem weg zu
gehen
sie malträtierten uns mit stöcken
das hatten sie echt drauf
um ruhe zu haben versuchte jeder mit
ihnen klar zu kommen
kein wunder dass fast alle häftlinge an
flucht denken
einige sprangen sogar ins wasser und
versuchten abzuhauen
gab es erfolgreiche fluchtversuche
und was führt schließlich zum ende von
san lucas
eine flucht schien nahezu unmöglich
selbst wenn einer es bis ins wasser
schaffte warteten dort schon die haie
und bis zum festland war es viel zu weit
gefangen im paradies keine chance zu
entkommen
[Musik]
viele schaffen es nicht mal bis ins
wasser
wer außerhalb des gefängnisses geländes
erwischt wurde konnte damit rechnen halb
totgeprügelt zu werden und landete im
loch
[Applaus]
die wachleute machen was sie wollen und
müssen nichts rechtfertigen
hier sind viele menschen begraben
bei einigen weiß keiner wer sie
umgebracht hat bei anderen weiß man
nicht wie sie umgekommen sind
[Musik]
schockierende foltermethoden spurlos
verschwundene insassen das allein wären
gute gründe das gefängnis zu schließen
aber vielleicht nicht die einzigen
lukas sei wegen der unmenschlichen
methoden geschlossen worden
aber das muss nicht die ganze wahrheit
sein
für eine weile hält sich das gerücht san
lucas solle in ein touristenparadies
verwandelt werden mit schönen hotels
kasinos und einem flugplatz
falls es pläne gab sie werden nie
verwirklicht das gefängnis trotzdem
geschlossen
ein glück für die insel
heute ist sein lukas ein
naturschutzgebiet tag für tag kommen
touristen
sie erfreuen sich sowohl an den ruinen
als auch an der atemberaubenden natur
[Musik]
jetzt gehört es wirklich zu jenen costa
rica das kennen und lieben
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie künden vom krieg
und terror vom erfindergeist und
menschlichen streben nach fortschritt